so we've got another Marvel movie for me
yes sir I do
coming up with original ideas for a
series with over 20 movies and it has
got to be getting difficult actually
it's super easy
barely an inconvenience oh really well
you remember how what stars we ripped
off Avengers endgame boy do I on your
left so there are more of us Poe I am
Iron Man and I am all the Jedi making
money off the same ideas in different
movies in the exact same year is tight
glad you think so sir because that's
exactly what I'd like to do to kick off
this next phase of Marvel oh really well
you know how he killed off Han Solo and
then inexplicably made a movie about his
backstory like a year later I mean Solo
right yeah yeah well I was thinking of
doing that exact same thing with MCU but
this time with Black Widow ah it sure is
easy to be creatively bankrupt when you
make all the movies it certainly is sir
but wait a minute wasn't solo a huge
flop whoopsie whoopsie
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show that has canceled all of its
red-carpet premieres for the foreseeable
future honestly those were a huge
expense for a YouTube channel anyway and
maybe we should have quit him earlier
but you know hole popped popcorn just
isn't the same I am going through butter
flavors substitute withdrawals here
people speaking of which appreciate this
video friends since it's likely the only
Marvel content that you'll be getting
for the better part of this year the
events of 2020 have resulted in a lot of
massive societal shifts but one of the
most interesting to think about has been
the absolute shattering of the Marvel
movie cycle that we've been on for
nearly a decade now one movie at the
beginning of the year and one at the end
sometimes if they were feeling ambitious
they throw one into the summer months -
it was nice it was just part of the
routine like the changing of the seasons
he had the changing of superhero posters
at your local AMC theater april showers
bring May flowers may star-lord brings
July spider-man it gave you something to
look forward to but now because of world
circumstances the house of cards that is
the Marvel Cinematic Universe has
started to tumble and making it even
worse at a time when it was already at
its most vulnerable
I mean 2020 was already gonna be a
stressful year for the MCU
you're coming off the conclusion of the
biggest cinematic story arc in history a
crossover of epic proportions with fan
favorites leaving and roles being passed
to a whole new generation of faces it's
already a pretty big shift now you have
to get people on board for the next big
thing to come
so that's challenge one challenge to
your house of cards suddenly has
expanded into much more content you're
no longer just asking audiences to
invest in two or maybe three movies a
year but now there's also Disney Plus
streaming shows that we have to watch oh
ok I already had a subscription to watch
Lizzie McGuire so I guess I'll fit in
one division and do I have to watch
Falcon in the Winter Soldier gotta be
honest I'm not particularly interested
in that one maybe we should start
calling this the Marvel connected
universe just to keep that same MCU
acronym because cinematic just isn't
accurate anymore will this newer bigger
universe collapse before it even gets
started at least they have this new
phase being kicked off by their biggest
stars
spider-man far from home in the
guardians of the oh wait that's right a
long time ago guardians the
see volume 3 was scheduled to release in
2020 as the second part of phase 4 smart
move get some of the most beloved
characters to lay the groundwork for all
the new adventures set to come
spider-man on earth and the guardians up
in space but in 2018 the series's
director James Gunn was fired off the
project only to be rehired a year later
but at that point the damage was done
guardians was pushed back to 2022
leaving the big welcome to phase 4
banner being hung on none other than
Black Widow a film that was already on
the bubble of being direct to streaming
starring a character who died in the
last movie not replan chalk all that up
to challenges three and four and now
everything has been pushed back with
Black Widow coming out in November with
the domino effect to every other release
date I mean I was just eager to get
through the 2020 movies and back to the
Thor's and dr. Strange's that I loved at
the top of 2021 but no gotta wait a
whole nother year for those guys and
that is challenge number five so after
years of dominating the box office and
tons of smooth sailing the Disney Marvel
Machine already had itself some rough
waters ahead and now they're even
rougher with Black Widow as the
figurehead at the front of the ship and
all of this is without me even
mentioning the intricately crafted story
arcs between franchises where characters
are introduced twists happen and those
ripple effects are felt through the next
wave of content all of which is
dependent on perfectly timed releases of
course that last point wouldn't matter
all that much if Black Widow were really
just an after-the-fact Phase three movie
that most people think it is I don't
think that's the case the more I see of
the Black Widow trailers the less I
think this is gonna be an empty filler
movie in the release slate despite the
world expecting Disney to just drop
Black Widow on to Disney Plus like
onward or just follow the home premiere
trend that a lot of other movie studios
are using these days Disney didn't do
that and beyond financials and contracts
and things I think there's a reason for
that a solid narrative reason that
affects the entirety of phase four
movies I think that they pushed back the
releases of two years worth of
productions so Black Widow would get a
chance in theaters because lack Widow is
gonna be as important to establishing
phase four of the MCU as Iron Man was to
establishing phase one because get this
I think they may be setting this whole
thing up for the next generation of
Avenger
a new team of evil Avengers known as the
Dark Avengers let's look at the facts
I've already spent some time in a
previous theory talking about how the
Black Widow trailers may have already
hinted at the true nature of taskmaster
that the he is actually a she Melina
Vostok off coming from the same training
program as Black Widow only with a chip
on her shoulder because Natasha Romanoff
is so much better at everything and also
left the rest of the girls trapped in
that awful program milena gets herself
injected with the Super Soldier Serum
and comes back to kill the friend who
left her and the rest of the widow
family cool that's all well and good a
taskmaster as I see him or her is just
our villain of the week in this case
kind of like ant-man two's ghost or Iron
Man two's whiplash he may come back here
or there but she's not the overarching
threat for the entirety of phase 4 but
there is another much more sinister and
further reaching villain marching across
this movie general Thunderbolt Ross
now many forgotten by this point but
Ross is actually one of the earliest
characters introduced into this whole
universe with his first appearance
happening way back in the second MCU
movie ever
2008 oft forgotten Incredible Hulk here
you have an unusual problem
you should talk you should listen
professor we were putting a team
together
who's we forgotten for good reason to
Twitter was buzzing the other day about
Iron Man 3 being the worst Marvel movie
it's serious guys have you watched
Incredible Hulk I mean look at those CGI
ABS
I've seen more realistic looking stomach
muscles on a PlayStation era Tekken
character now in that movie general Ross
was the bad guy hunting down the Hulk
but since then he's been more or less a
neutral force in the film's acting as US
Secretary of State with his biggest act
coming in the form of the sokovia
accords from Civil War the past four
years you've operated with unlimited
power and no supervision that's an
arrangement the governments of the world
can no longer tolerate I think we have a
solution
sokovia accords but there's a lot more
to this character than meets the eye his
sinister nature has always dwelled just
below the surface and in 2008 Marvel
Comics transformed Ross from a mortal
military leader into something a lot
more fearsome the Red Hulk an
uninhibited tactically intelligent
adversary for our lovable
guy in the comic story line he was
created as part of yet another Super
Soldier program led in part by the
criminal organization known as
Intelligencia now here's where things
get interesting you see well the
Intelligencia and its core members have
yet to appear in the MCU one of its key
allies and partners for creating the Red
Hulk has appeared in the MCU advanced
idea mechanics or aim for short I'm a
proposal I'm putting together myself
it's a privately funded think tank
called advanced idea mechanics
we're aimed for sure you see in Iron Man
3 while everyone was busy complaining
about the Mandarin aim was working in
the background pulling the strings
they created the extremest program which
made super soldiers in possession of
heat-based ability breathing fire now
Red Hulk doesn't exactly work the same
way Green Hulk does when Red Hulk gets
angry instead of getting stronger he
gets hotter wait a minute didn't we just
say that aim was making heat-based super
soldiers in Iron Man 3 and we know that
in Black Widow Ross is gonna be playing
a big part and that the plot will have
to do at least in part with the return
of the Super Soldier Serum so now if
only we could confirm that aim was gonna
be a part of this movie we'd have
ourselves a pretty strong case for Red
Hulk appearing sometime before the end
of the film and would you look at that
aim is gonna be making an appearance in
Black Widow see if you freeze frame and
look at the medical equipment at the
bottom of the screen you can clearly see
a I M marked on the side so we have the
man who will become Red Hulk the project
that made the Red Hulk and the return of
the MC use evil scientist organization
known for making heat based soldiers all
combined into this one movie seems like
it's more than just a coincidence
now all that alone would be noteworthy
but that scene with Yelina on the gurney
is interesting for another reason not
only does it introduce a m-- back into
the MCU but it also reflects a plot from
the comics with some bizarre
implications if you look closely at that
freeze-frame you'll notice that yalena
below va's face has a neat little seam
running along the top nope that's not
our hairline and it's not a wig that's
been snatched you see the Marvel
breakdown comics involved Natasha
getting facial surgery to look just like
Yelena she does this to convince Yelena
that super spy dome is dangerous which
you know you don't
facial swap surgery to really do its
called watching any Jason Bourne movie
ever anyway if this scene is real and
not just manufactured for the trailer it
looks like the MCU might be trying to
follow in the comics footsteps with
yalena hosing as Natasha or Natasha
posing as Yelena one of the two again I
don't know why you need to take it that
far considering that in Winter Soldier
Natasha had herself some pretty
convincing facial disguise technology
but again super spies gotta be super but
here's the twist my friends what if the
facial swap doesn't end with this movie
so Yelena and Natasha swap identities or
faces or whatever maybe Natasha's
trapped in prison or something and
Yelena is going out posing as her big
whoop
right think again remember how an
infinity war and end game
black widows hair was blond rather than
the usual red the change was never
explained in continuity the characters
definitely had bigger issues to deal
with a Natasha's choice of hair color
but it was kind of strange to see this
famously redheaded character just go
blonde for a movie and a half for no
reason we all just dismissed it as a way
to mix up the look of her character keep
her identity hidden while she's a
fugitive from the government her heck
just sell more black widow toys now with
blonde hair action but what if the
blonde hair was an indicator that this
isn't the real Black Widow the one that
we know and love and continue to
question why she belongs in a team full
of gods and tech billionaires now hair
alone wouldn't be all that much evidence
but what about the vest we see it in the
trailers for Black Widow Yelena is
wearing a tactical vest no sleeves two
snaps along the neck three double
bracketed straps that wrap around the
body all warned and a half zip it is the
exact same vest that we see Natasha or
Natasha wearing an infinity war during
the subway fight scene to protect vision
a tactical vest no sleeves two snaps
along the neck three double bracketed
straps that wrap around the body all
worn in a half zip originally I thought
that Marvel Studios was gonna do exactly
what Marvel Comics attempted in 2002
replacing Natasha Romanov with Yelena
Bulova as the new Black Widow that year
Marvel released an entire year's worth
of black widow comics without Natasha
but that wasn't a super popular decision
after a year's hiatus the Black Widow
comic returned with Natasha back in the
main role and
Leyna cast as a villain moving forward
and that made us be our biggest clue as
to Elena's real purpose in the MCU
between Ross's involvement in the movie
and Yelena's likely impersonation of
Natasha I believe Yelena is gonna become
the first member of MC use Thunderbolts
eventually leading to the reveal of a
new team of villains the Dark Avengers
let's start with the Thunderbolts this
is a weird little Marvel team that has
wildly varied members depending on what
version it is but the general idea is
that Thunderbolts look like superheroes
on the surface but are more of
supervillains in disguise or superheroes
being misled by a super villain Red Hulk
ran a Thunderbolts team consisting of
heroes like The Punisher who eventually
turned on him when he realized that Ross
was up to no good and wiped out almost
the entire team other notable leaders of
the Thunderbolts include Baron Helmut
Zemo and Norman Osborn both of these
figures are upcoming in the MCU Baron
Zemo was already in civil war and we
know that he's making a return in Falcon
and the Winter Soldier we also also know
that a twist in Black Widow will be
important for Falcon in the Winter
Soldier so the connections there just
continue to deepen all of it is a major
indicator that the Thunderbolts are
gonna be playing a large role moving
forward and Yelena could serve as a
perfect member of that almost heroes
supervillain team as for Norman well
he's already been hinted at and
spider-man far from home as we covered
in a previous theory so if Norman Osborn
does indeed join the Thunderbolt crew
well it'll give Marvel the chance to
upgrade the Thunderbolts to the Dark
Avengers
it's exactly what Norman Osborn did in
the comics he joined the group he took
it over and then he made them into the
Dark Avengers and think about it we may
already be on our way there an evil hulk
and an evil Black Widow things are
definitely starting to take shape and
heck we all know that the most exciting
storylines are when the heroes end up
fighting themselves I mean that's what
the Power Rangers taught me so there you
have it friends why Black Widow maybe
more worth our time than anyone expected
and why Disney really wants to make sure
it releases in theaters now the biggest
obstacle standing in the hero's way
isn't past master or Thunderbolt Ross or
even the Dark Avengers it's just an
enemy that's too small and too difficult
for any of them to overcome now it's
just a waiting game for the real
world heroes to save the day so we can
finally get back to watching the
fictional ones on screen but hey that's
just a theory a film theory
[Music]
you